STARTING AGAIN 6:30 P.M.
EASTERN TIME.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
NORTH KOREA HAS JUST TEST FIRED
A NEW TACTICAL GUIDED WEAPON.
ACCORDING TO THE ASSOCIATED
PRESS.
KIM JONG-UN IS SAID TO HAVE
COMMENTED KOREAN CENTRAL NEWS
AGENCY SAYS CHAIRMAN KIM
JONG-UN OBSERVED THE FIRE OF
THE WEAPON.
KIM SAID THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
WEAPONS SYSTEMS SERVES AN EVENT
OF WEIGHTY SIGNIFICANCE IN
INCREASING THE COMBAT POWER OF
THE PEOPLE'S ARMY.
THE AGENCY SAYING KIM MOUNTED
AN OBSERVATION POST TO LEARN
ABOUT THE TESTIFIER OF THIS NEW
TYPE OF TACTICAL GUIDED WEAPON
AND ALSO GUIDED THE TEST FIRING
OF IT.
IT CAME AFTER REPORTS OF NEW
ACTIVITY AT THE NORTH KOREAN
MISSILE RESEARCH CENTER.
ALL OF THIS COMING ON THE BACK
DROP OF WHAT HAS BEEN VERY
ACTIVE MOVEMENTS BY NORTH KOREA
OVERALL.
THE WHITE HOUSE NOT COMMENTING
AT THIS MOMENT ON THIS NEW TEST